I prepared a bunch of position centered
around the team and I thought I would
start with just showing you a puzzle and
then let you guys try and figure out
what the fee might be so this is white
to move it is not coming from the actual
game it's a study and in this position
it looks like white is just losing
because H pawn is just going to promote
in a very short time and the King is
very far away on b3 so like to move and
survive yeah this is take some
creativity and actually what you said is
not quite right you said King a4 so King
a4 okay let's imagine so if you play
King a4 first then black will play c4
and you can't do the genius stalemated
yet so you have to play c4 first and
just for those of you who didn't catch
what what you said h4 White's moves are
just automatic and there's nothing black
can do to on stalemate white and it's
just a draw if we look at another line
let's say black sea's is coming and
after c4 black plays Keeney - what does
white do
so lacks ideas to take on c4 it's exact
same thing yeah I was trying to trick
you guys but in reality the fact that
blacks capturing the c-pawn makes no
difference is a for wherever the King
moves it's still stalemate okay I'm
going to give you guys one more slightly
different but related position it's just
uh modify this a little bit and I've
shown this to many students over the
years and a lot of them initially get it
wrong same position white to move only
this time the pawn is on h4 rather than
h5 and the question is can white draw
using the same idea or is there a way
for black to win Oh time is very
important you don't want to waste time
because yeah c3 which just makes make
blacks life a lot easier so yeah so I
want everyone to calculates I'm not
going to move the pieces but I'll just
say the line and try and just visualize
the position so why play c4 black plays
h3y plays King a4 black plays h2 King
a5h one Queen a for this black have any
move there to to keep the game going so
what's the conclusion draw
does anyone think it's not a draw
everyone thinks it's a job mm-hmm there
we go
so black is winning amazingly enough the
extra tempo is actually very very
important so if we actually play the
moves and this is hard to see in advance
but you promote to Queen and then the
only move to keep the game going it's
actually sacrifice the Queen pawn takes
pawn take and this is a very straight
forward when King b5 d4 black we'll just
promote the pomp and to go back one more
funny thing you could also promote to
vision so all other winning move here
same idea Bishop d5 so two winning moves
for black in that position so there's a
few themes that I want to take from this
puzzle and then apply it to the other
positions we'll see the first theme is
thinking outside the box I think a lot
of players would see this position as
white and give up pretty easily maybe
play a move like King c-4 or just resign
CMH ponds coming down the board and
that's actually referring to the
position with opponent h5 so I want you
guys to focus on or keep in mind is when
you're in kind of a hopeless or
seemingly lost position that you look
for creative ideas because sometimes
sometimes miracles can happen and
sometimes you'll have an idea to to come
back and save the position so that's
what the theme is going to be about
today is saving lost or hopeless
positions and we'll see a kind of an
array of ideas we'll see a few games
stop me if you have any questions try
and make this as interactive as possible
okay this puzzle okay we'll start off
easy and then get to a bit more
difficult points so this is white to
move I saw this type of idea as a very
much beginner white just has a knight
and rook and white to move save the game
and black wants to mate next move
so the problem is if you don't play a
forcing move right away and you play a
move like rook g7 you're getting mated
rook F on rook h18 so the only move
really is nice e6 yeah and yes so the
idea is not stalemate but it's perpetual
is after Knight a seven the king is just
trapped if the King moves back you
repeats if the King moves to b8 you
still repeat and the only player that
can win this position is white if black
missteps and plays King eights then
there's rook a seven mates yeah so I had
this only once in a game and my opponent
actually walked into the corner and got
mated in a better position so you want
to be careful for this and also goes
back to the concepts that even though it
looks like White's losing at first
there's a his idea to not only save the
game but also creates some some chance
to win the game
and we'll see this a lot in n games
especially with knights and rooks and
actually I guess a thousand years ago
the rules of chess were different and
like Queens and bishops were less
powerful but rooks and knights still
have the same powers so especially like
in older chess the Knights and the rooks
would coordinate very well and they
still do today as we see in this
position so let's move on just go in
order here
this one is going to be a lot more
difficult so I think what I'll do is
I'll give you guys the first move or two
and then I'll have you come up with a
final idea so this is white to move and
draw or it's sorry white to move and not
lose it might be a draw
lady white will win as we can see black
is - two moves away from queening and it
seems pretty hopeless so Bishop is
completely out of play
there is no way to control the the a1
square and just to
moves you would love to somehow get the
bishop to like be to but some just takes
too long so I'm going to give you guys
the first Bishop f6 and now a2 and I'll
let you guys think for a little bit in
this position white to move we know
blacks next move you have to figure out
how not to let black to Queen yeah
c4 only move and now a black really only
has one response King c5 if black takes
on passant and we simply recapture with
the bishop and this is actually a win
for white the fact that white is
controlling these 3 squares pretty much
creates a barricade that the King can't
pass and also the bishop controls a 1 so
white will very simply win this by
walking that came back probably picking
up the pawn first and in the meantime
there's nothing black can do make sense
to everyone
so c4 king c5 now I would guess a good
number of chess players would resign in
this position as white it seems like a1
queen is coming what to do
at Bishop e7 check you you delay
promotion for one more move but then
what
and now white can actually resign King
b2 King b7 Queen louder check a lot of
checkmate
turns out white was winning the whole
time completely unexpected but this is
mates and sometimes when your opponent's
king is in the center and you just have
bishop couple pawns you're not thinking
about mates yeah and sometimes you see
the idea before you see the actual move
if you see that blacks king is sort of
limited on squares you might look start
looking for ways to to control all the
squares so if they don't promote then
blacks observe long black would have to
move away from the D pawn so some move
like King OOP after King b7 let's say
King b4 we just take the D pawn easy one
yeah so yeah earlier I said white to
move and draw but this is this is just
winning for white Bishop f6 nothing
black can do okay any questions so far
okay we'll keep moving on so in this
position it was about creating counter
play it was black had a strong threat of
promoting but we had a bigger threat of
me and we'll see that occur a few more
times let's look at this game as I
wanted to incorporate a few games in
addition to the puzzles so when I was
preparing materials for this lecture I
thought I would show this game it's
actually the very first game I played at
the st. Louis chess club it was back
into
ten I qualified for the US Junior
Championship and it was the first time
they held that you use at this location
and in the first round I was paired
against Ray Robson who is now my current
teammates at the time he was the top
seed in tournaments he was actually I
believe the only GN in the field out of
all the juniors and it wasn't easy
playing him first round because I was
the lowest rated player in the
tournament
most people were over 2,400 so we were
playing where we're playing a pretty
hard fought game and we got to this
position where it's very very messy and
I will say that we were playing with the
time control where you get an extra half
hour on move 40 so leading up to move 40
we both had probably under five minutes
left and if I could recall correctly he
played the move King age seven with a
few seconds left
and he aged seven turns out to be a
pretty bad Bunder I'll leave it open to
you guys white to move and play the
completely winning move 96 yeah simply
forking the rook and the Queen and
whatever black does you take one of them
with check so when I played this move I
was of course very excited I'm beating
the top seed I thought he was going to
resign I would just win but that's not
raised style at all he likes to fight
and if he has any any hope or any life
in the position he will not resign and
you'll see this in a lot of his games so
he he continued the game you played
Queen d2 and actually one of my mistakes
in this game was I got too emotional too
soon and that happens a lot in chess
when you're winning a game you might sit
back relax and think the position will
play itself but that's usually when
players are most likely to make mistakes
so next time you're winning a chess game
or you think you're completely winning
still try and stay focused because
that's one of the ways people screw up
loss positions
or winning positions and unfortunately
that happened to me in this game so I
didn't win this position and I started a
playing the most obvious move I take F 8
nothing wrong with this King h6 and now
I have a few options black is
threatening mates in one queen h2 so any
idea is how to stop Queen h2 for whites
Queen F for any other moves 23 anything
else so during the game these were the
only two moves I considered which is the
first mistake and I thought both of them
were winning so I play Queen afore
quickly and the game kept going it turns
out I could have ended the game right
away
yeah rookie - very good and then look
yeah and this just this ends things
right away because I'm distracting the
Queen from the fourth rank and after
take its it should be forced made
somehow Queen f4 f g5 Queen f6 mates and
if King g7 it's just made there or King
h6
pretty nice mate with 96 so if I played
rookie to the game would have ended
interference but I miss rookie - I play
Queen f4 which is still winning but it
it gives some chances to come back and
he he made full use of these chances so
take take I'm up a full rook so I
thought nothing of it and it's move 41
so we both got in additional half-hour
so time time pressure isn't a factor I
have to be concerned with and yep but
the a pawn yeah and actually I went to
the bathroom after playing rook take out
four and I came back and then a2 was on
the board and then I realized it wasn't
so easy even though I'm up a rock I
can easily just defend the first rank I
could play rook f1 I realized that he
has some ideas of Bishop a6 Bishop d3
rook be to maybe put the rook or Bishop
on d1 and also I'm a little bit tied
down to the e pawn with the bishop on
the same diagonal as my king so so I
realize this this is not easy to win and
what's that
o h4 yeah you want to create the mating
net right h4 yeah maybe h4 would have
been better than what I played maybe g5
rook f6 King g7
oh you want to play rook f7 bishop take
efore it's complicated and maybe even
after h4 maybe rook e1 is slightly
better but there's all these tactics for
black that White has to be concerned
about so what I did in this position
simply play d5 to block out the vision
which wasn't a bad move gets rid of all
these Bishop to g4 ideas array plays
rook b2 and okay now the the idea is
very clear he wants to play rook b1 and
then just promote the pawn so in this
position I went pretty wrong and then
then I actually had to save the position
myself
turns out White has a brilliant way of
winning this and it's really not that
obvious I think if I gave this position
to like a strong GM they would they
would have to think about it for a
little bit so I'm just going to show you
guys the win for whites it's to play
rook f7 and the whole idea is just
creating a mating next
the threat is rook h7 followed by 96
mates an idea is after rook b1l rook b1
I'm sorry goes into the same thing rook
h7 and 96 mates what did I want to show
oh yeah
King g5 and now the idea is that white
will succeed in creating the mating nuts
any ideas for whites I'm actually
struggling to remember this because I
remember the idea it was it was
something like rookie f1 or rook g1 and
I think I'm just going to go ahead and
cheat because this is really just a
computer solution assuming the engine is
strong enough Komodo
oh there's sound effects rook g1 really
I don't think so so the idea of being
okay rook be one king h2 and okay this
is a computer line and really I put
myself in a situation where I probably
would have had to find the computer line
to to win the game and it was a bad
situation to put myself in but as we can
see okay mate it's coming if h4 we just
take take 96 that's pretty sweet mate
with rook h7 next move
exactly yeah so this key move rook G 1
followed by King H 2 not the easiest
thing to find so if we go back
I didn't play rook at 7 I played a worse
move I played rook F 6 which threatens
mates but allows King G 7 and then I had
to move back with the rook and actually
I chose a wrong square here for the rook
I played rook F 1 which I think draws
our game right away I still have one
more chance to win by playing rook F 3
and this applies to a lot of endgame
situations where if you're choosing a
square to put your piece usually want to
choose a more active Square and rook F 1
is certainly more passive with rook F 3
the idea would be to play rook a3 and
defend from from a file and I'm missing
something rook b1
oh yeah rook b1 then I would play rook
f1 and okay the it's not a clear win now
after a1 Queen rook take b1 but white
certainly has great winning chances here
with the two rooks versus the Queen so
I'll show you what happened the game
rook f1 Bishop a6 so I'm up a full rook
but now he's getting enough counter play
to the point where I have to be very
careful
I played 96 King h6 and then then I just
I found a repetition and I just went for
it realizing that if I allow Bishop d3
followed by Bishop b1 I could easily
lose so I played rook F eights and then
black really has no choice but to also
take the draw after king age 795 and
it's just repetition King makes F King
age six is never possible due to rook h8
meet so it was a slightly disappointing
round one for both of us as he drew a
player 400 points below him and I drew
him up a full rook so goes to show that
sometimes you shouldn't resign even if
it looks losing you should continue
playing and and try and get counter play
and try and complicate matters because
that's that's how you're going to come
back and and save worse or lost
positions speaking of never resign let's
take a look at this game I don't want to
embarrass anyone but I guess I'm sort of
forced to with this game so we're going
to jump straight to the final position
now since the theme is coming back from
worse positions I thought this this game
fit in pretty well cuz it looks like
black is just winning here after the
move king h6 uh black is simply
threatening to Queen and it white
doesn't have any checks and if white
plays some move like Queen c2 then black
will simply play Queen F line
then promotes so the question is after
king h6 should should white resign or is
there a way to play on and actually save
the game Queen b7 so black will play the
same idea queen f1 king h2 Queen now
like your design a problem is if you
move your your King you you allow be one
Queen right so the key the key component
about this position for white is
creating counter play and you have to do
so in a way which also defends against
the threat defends against be one Queen
so look for a move which aims to somehow
exploit the king but at the same time
keeps an eye on the b-pawn
that queen bee it's the only move so
queen f1 Jack King h2 and black has no
time to Queen because queen h8 mates so
it turns out that the best black can do
here is give or give a perpetual black
has no way to create anything because
there's a may threat and if you if you
cover the may threat like King h7 you
just lose the b-pawn so the game
probably would have ended very quickly
after Queen f2 and just as both players
can agree to a draw so this can be very
painful resigning in a position which is
like just completely drawn but it does
happen and it happens too much stronger
players but like the key thing is never
resign if you still feel like there's
life left and even if you don't feel
like there's life left
don't resign I mean move on let me show
you one more example of why you should
never resign
no matter the opponent's a funny example
Karpov risk polgár maybe some people
have seen this at least this n game
before Karpov I mean played his typical
Karpov style completely outplayed Pulgar
and he got into a completely winning
position I'm not actually sure if this
was like a blitz or rapid match but for
some reason Pulgar wasn't resigning kept
playing on even after Karpov promoted
and in this position why it made the
terrible mistake Queen f3 and it's just
stalemate and this this thing happens
and that's why if like even if you're
playing like a much higher rate of
player don't resign because if carpod
can still meets a player like or if
sorry if yeah if carpod can still me the
player like this and anyone can doesn't
happen too often but it it pays off if
you're if you're not resigning and it
does it does happen so let's let's move
on let's do a few more puzzles which
kind of stay with the theme okay I'm
gonna give you guys a few like King pawn
endings because I think these are little
overlooked in terms of what people study
and I know like most people are not good
at the endgame because I prioritize
studying tactics and openings and I
think it's important to have like a good
foundational and game understanding and
to know some some kind of famous
concepts and being able to apply it so
this is yeah this is famous position
named after ready this is white to move
and draw it looks like black should win
by just pushing the H pawn but I'm
assuming at least a few of you have seen
this before and I think I might just
walk through it for those of you who
haven't seen it white will draw by
moving the King closer to the black pawn
and the white pawn and to do that
you have to move on this diagonal and
this is one of the interesting things
about geometry in chess when you move
along the diagonal actually moving
closer to both pawns
so first move of course King g7 and now
there's a few different variations here
but we'll start with with simply H for
let's say King f6 and now black has two
moves let's say King b6 simply going
after the C pawn white to move
if you know what you can shout it out
louder
kingi five just continuing along the
diagonal and this move is actually a
fork and you're not forking to pieces
but you're forking two squares you're
threatening both King d6 and king f4 and
depending on what black does you're
going to play one of these moves so if
black takes upon you simply play king f4
and you have everything covered this is
a dead draw and then slightly more
complicated is if black plays h3 then
you you give up on trying to stop the H
pawn and you go and support your C pawn
and after h2 you're just in time if H
one Queen C a queen and if King b7 then
just King g7 and it's a dead draw let's
look at one more line let's say let's
say after King g7 let me test you guys
let's say King b6 white to move
King at six still yeah and it's pretty
much just a transposition
what if h4 king e5 same exact position
very good so this is a this is kind of
the simple idea
now next positional show is a bit more
complex and I've shown this to students
before with it where they'll solve this
position and then they will just
completely freak out on the next
position this is a lot scarier black is
up to pawns basically three on one white
to move and draw so what's the move King
g6 let's say King b6 and it's actually
very simple once you know the previous
position this is now a transposition
actually if white plays h5 or if black
plays h5 same exact position as we just
saw and just remember this fork with
King e5 now there are a few other lines
given that black does have three pawns
on the Kings side so let me test you
guys let's see if you can draw in all
these lines let's say h5 you have to
capture a pawn but which crime yeah so
capturing h5 is actually a this decisive
mistake you're moving too far away and
after king b6 if you try and go back to
g6
this is just an easy win for black
because eventually one of the palms will
promote so I think by process of
elimination if we know we want to take
upon and it's not the H pawn it has to
be the Jeep on well it's it's kind of
deceiving but after h4 King take f6 it's
the same position as last time actually
last time we didn't look at one line we
saw King V six and then King G five but
what if h3 here
why to move and draw yeah kini 7 you
just you forget about H pawn you're
close enough to help your C pawn and if
King v6 you you simply support the pawn
and both players will Queen
so yeah h5 it's slightly tricky what
about let me see if I can trick you one
more time let's say King g6 you take on
g7 now let's say f5 White's move at King
up 6 don't take the H pawn because you
have to move closer to your C pawn as
well so ok have 4 kini 5 very good so
now you're forking you're actually
forking a square and upon
if black allows you to take the F pawn
it's a dead draw and if f3 then you just
go forward King d6 and you see the same
thing and now one might argue that
there's very slim chances for black with
extra H pawn but this is this is a
pretty easy draw because there's pretty
much no shelter for the black King but
this would be the I if I had this
position as black in a game and my
opponent played perfectly I would
definitely go for this line with with
that 5 so any questions about this
position pretty high level position but
I think if you understand how the
alimentary idea then you can grasp this
more complex situation I've had this
position myself in three different
tournament games across the course of my
career and it's kind of a typical
position you might get into thinking it
should be an easy win for white rook
into vs. just a just one rook but I've
seen a lot of people mess this up
actually the three times I've gotten to
this position
two of them were draws and both both
draw
I had the the worst side I had the black
side and both my opponents actually
walked into some sale matrix so I just
want to show you one example line of how
white could easily mess this up and I'll
show you the correct way for white to
wink so so I'm just going to play some
moves I think I've the line saved and
this is usually the approach for light
white we'll just push up both pawns in
the King and let's say let's say h7
let's say g6 doesn't seem like anything
wrong yet but it turns out g6 draws the
game black to move and find the easy
draw rook c5 King h6 rook h5 and this is
one of the problems a lot of people
forget about is the fact that black can
give away the rook and just end up in
stalemate so when you're playing light
you have to be extra careful about this
idea and this same idea
it's called crazy rook or mad rook it
doesn't just apply to this position but
it really applies to any position where
you have just a rook and your King
stalemate and you want to give it away
for free so if we go back White has to
be extra careful not to allow these sort
of stalemate ideas so I'll give you guys
a pretty simple technique to win this
position and I will say I actually had
this this exact position or not this
exact position but this exact endgame a
less than a week ago in the last round
of the Pan Am collegiate tournament and
I opponent actually resigned in in a
position like this without even going
for stale matrix I think my opponent
just assumed that I I would know how to
win which I did so I guess there's no
energy loss there but the the easy way
for white to win is first to put the
rook on a5 you want to put the pawn on
g6 and not allow any checks on the
fifth-ranked and black is pretty much
forced to weights I mean you can weight
with the rook on the back rank
or wait with the king by moving to h7 I
should note that if the rook moves off
the back rank then there would just be a
simple mates if g6 so let's say black
waits and displays rook b8 then you're
going to just put the pawn on g6 black
will have to continue waiting and then
you put the rook on f5 and now if you
can remember the setup with the King on
h5 rook on f5 pawns on g6 and h6 then
this endgame pretty much becomes a
no-brainer it's just a matter of
executing a one or two more ideas so
black now has two choices black in
either continue waiting with the rook or
move the King both of which leg will
have a very straightforward win let's
say King g8 first a easy win is h7 King
h8 now King h6 and if we know this
there's no possible way for black to
sacrifice the rook and either g7 or rook
f8 are coming depending on what lactose
and I should note that if King g7 it's
pretty much the same thing you just play
rook f7 check first and then look King
h6 so the the other option for black is
to leave the King on h8 and just play
like some move like rook a8 and this is
one of my more favorite lines to show
because I think it's it's pretty
aesthetic and the way white wins the
move that I would choose here and I was
pretty upset that I didn't get to do
this in my turn making so I was planning
on it let's play rook f8 sacking the
rook but getting into a completely
winning endgame despite not having a
rook if King G eights
light will simply play king g6 and
there's really no good way to stop each
seven
it's only move Rick at 6:00 and then
just take and this is easy one if we go
back what move would you guys play here
what's the best try for black King age
seven right
the only other legal move hoping that
white will not pay attention to what
they're promoting to or if this is an
online game hoping your opponent has
Auto Queen in this case chess bass
doesn't have all the Queen you don't
want to promote to a queen and you don't
want to promote to a rook but you can
promote tonight or Bishop and both both
pieces win Bishop is maybe easier and
then you just make sure it's the right
color square yeah but it's one of the
rare examples of under promotions so so
do you guys think you could win this as
White's easily it's any one against me
or against Ben Feingold or against
Magnus Carlsen now maybe depending on
the time situation yeah that's true and
it's also very important to kind of have
a general knowledge at like common end
games because usually by the time you
reach the endgame you're low on time and
you want to make sure that you have like
a kind of foundational knowledge to to
fall back on so you're not having to
rely on figuring things out but you
already kind of know what to do in the
position like a machine yes okay let's
move on I have a few more King pawn
examples which I thought I would show
you because I've used these on occasion
to trick my opponents and and save very
bad positions so let's flip the board
this is black to move black is down the
pawn tore down upon should probably
loose should lose if white faced
cracking
but this is black to move and be tricky
so you want to play a move for a black
which gives you some chances a four very
good and a four is not a winning move
but it creates the most possibilities
for white to go wrong and sometimes
that's all you can do when you're in a
losing position is just give your
opponent chances to mess up and this is
interesting because now White has only
one move to win the game someone said
something a three yeah there's only
winning move for whites everything else
actually loses from what I can see black
is of course planning a breakthrough
black wants to play a three next and if
white goes wrong and play something like
see take b4 then black will play a three
and I've seen so many games I play the
few games where this has happened and
and white will Lutz so that's why when
you're in a winning position you of
course have to look for your opponent's
count opponents counter play opponents
ideas before you look at your own ideas
so a three just blocks up everything
whatever black takes white takes back
and you guys understand how to win this
you basically just walk the King over
forget about the G pawn and then when
the Queen side pawns okay let's look at
one more example okay so another
position same theme this is white to
move white is completely lost but I'm
not looking for you to find the like
winning or drawing move I'm looking for
you to create the most chances as
possible so what would you play as
lights if you're trying to trick your
opponent you would just resign okay
hopefully after this lecture you won't
resign even even in the position like
this
yeah unfortunately five isn't that
tricky g5 black will either take or play
h5 and then win on the queenside king b2
it's not not as tricky as you can be in
this position the trickiest move is h5
because now you actually have a threat
and you're putting black in a situation
or it has to be somewhat careful to not
mess things up it looks like you don't
have a threat it looks like black and
just continue play some like King before
or b4 but if this were to happen white
now wins g5 and this is your threat a
very classic pawn break and it's pretty
amazing because you're breaking through
with just two pawns against three pawns
but you're able to do it with with first
playing h5 and actually probably hurts
black to have a pawn here because it
looks like White's not writing anything
but um black would either have to play
g5 or take so after something like b4 g5
flight lengths if take you take and your
queen first and if take you play h6 and
black is just not quick enough
whew winning moves for white probably
the easiest is queen eights and just
pick up the g2 pawn so residing is
usually the worst possible move or the
worst thing you can do in a position
because you're not going to give
yourself any hope to have any result of
a loss let me show you guys one more
game and then we'll end kind of with the
challenge physician this is a game which
is probably pretty painful for my
opponents actually a previous GM in
residence Josh Vidal item if you saw any
of his lectures I know he's had some
lectures on the endgame which I've seen
on YouTube
um his very good teacher and very good
player but unfortunately this game he he
let me loose from a completely winning
position so we're gonna zoom forward we
put it in training and you can probably
see how bad the position is already for
me I'll just move forward it gets worse
I was suffering most of the game but
somehow I kept holding on kept holding
on and then we got to this position now
it's still equal material rook and
Bishop and four pawns versus rook Bishop
four pawns the problem is I'm White's
and I have almost no moves if we look at
what can move in the position my King is
completely tied down to the bishop the
bishop is pinned to the a pawn bishop is
also tied down to the e pawn seems like
the only piece that can move is the rook
but if the rook moves then there's rook
a to check a rook H to check and then I
think it's just over after King III with
rook h1 coming or Bishop being lost on
d3 so I think a lot of players maybe
would consider resigning this position
but white to move and really the using
the theme from today is you want to look
for ways to create counter play even if
your positions lost look for ways to
create chances so white to move and try
and be aggressive pawn c5 mmm take
Brooksie for it's pretty ugly for whites
maybe okay maybe it's possible
rook h2 check and knowledge of it
the thing is no line for light will look
so good but you want to look for a line
which gives you some hope some chance
that's true but that's why I played I
play defy it's really my only move which
creates some sort of hope
sure and he probably should have taken
with the King but he took with upon
which and then c5 very good it turns out
it's still completely lost for whites
I mean I'm giving up pawns hoping to
somehow Queen might be pawn but it's
it's not going to work if he if he plays
accurately and he just plays e4 of
threatening to take the bishop with with
the rook with check i had to retreat
bishop f1 rogue h2 king c1 many trades
and now didn't want to go that far now
it's his move he has a variety of
winning moves he could take the C pawn
maybe the easiest way to win because
after b6 there is Bishop c8 and then I
know earlier we saw the King versus the
three pawns but this position three
pawns for black is more than enough to
win another way to win is to simply play
King III and then it's just a matter if
whatever white does we play d3 check and
then I think the pawn just promotes
without too much difficulty
if King C one D to check if King C 3 up
probably just d1 anyway or d2
and should be an easy win for black eyed
b7d one and then simply mates so there
were many ways for black to win this but
he played one of the only moves which
doesn't win and it's actually one of the
problems when you've been better for so
long in a chess game and you're just
looking to kind of find that knockout
punch move sometimes it's not easy and
sometimes it takes a bit more focus than
you would normally expect and in this
position he got careless for one move he
plays d3 and now White's a move Bishop
take d3 and now it's a dead draw and
Roncalli Bishop which I think been
Feingold just had a lecture about like
within the last few weeks point being if
take take pawn takes e5 i flaking c4 and
I'll win the C pawn and then the bishop
is not the same color as the queening
square for a pawn so d3 was played I
took and then of course he realized that
the positions now drawn but he still
tried to fight on he took on c5 and I
still have to be careful here because I
am down upon and he still has ideas of
maybe taking the bishop and white does
have to be accurate so any ideas most
accurate move for white here
a bishop f1 is possible but there's no
reason to move the bishop if I can play
b6 and that's why I played and then I
force him to retreats try not he still
can't take because the same type of ID I
would win the C pawn so he plays Bishop
to c8 I played Bishop b5 and then then
it was just a simple matter of drawing
the game what ended up happening is he
did win my bishop by playing e2 take
take king c3 Bishop a6 white to move and
play the easy drawing move at simply b7
Bishop is overworked take and then King
c4 so even against a GM if you seem
completely lost I mean there there is
hope to come back I keep saying that
over and over but I think too many
people give up without trying as hard as
they can and hopefully this will help
save save you guys from losing or or
drawing some games I I don't know if you
any of you were here earlier today but
Fabiano stopped by I saw him very
briefly and I am i regretted like not
getting the opportunity to show him this
puzzle but if you have your comes by
I'll show them this because I think this
is one of the most difficult problems
that there is and it's relatively simple
I think for like once you actually know
the idea but I don't want to give too
much away so this is white to move at
first it seems like White's lost a pawn
is going to Queen and I'll let you guys
try and absorb this a little bit if
anyone has an idea for white to try and
survive the game feel free to shout it
out I will say that I don't think any of
you will actually solve this h6 okay I
was waiting for someone to say h6
um let's say a - problem is you're just
a little too slow
h7 a1 Queen rook g7 IC King e6 I'll tell
you there's a lot of lines like this
where you might get some checks with the
rook in the Knights but none of them
work and the idea is actually a lot
simpler and it's actually a one move
solution amazingly enough
so I think what I'm better off doing is
showing you the first move and then
having you guys try and figure out why
it actually draws so I think like when I
first saw this first move I didn't
understand it but then then there's
there should be an aha moment where
you'll realize why it's so brilliant so
the only move for white to save the game
9 H 6 looks like the most random move
ever but it has one simple idea let's
say a two turns out there's nothing much
better black can do in this position
think back to the a queen we take so
yeah I know earlier like we talked about
stalemate ideas we talked about like I
encounter play I will tell you this
position it's perpetual check rook g7
and all you have to do is keep checking
the king with your rook on the G file
and there's nowhere that King can find
shelter my king can't even attack the
rook because the knight the geometry
with the Knights the fact that the King
supports you squares so we see a lot of
beauty with the coordination of the fact
that the pawn controls g6 is very
important so this is a study yeah
it's named the the guy who created it
his last name is jaha DJ aja and this
has been given by to some of the top
players in the world has been many top
players who have failed to solve this so
actually I gave this to Ray Robson
several months ago and it took him about
five minutes before he found that h6 and
maybe what's even more funny
prepare yourself for a sound effect if
we turn on Komodo
Komodo will not find not eh6 so the idea
is just to deep it seeds that blacks
cleaning blocks up material and Eve oh
it does found 96 yeah Wow computers got
stronger but it's it's still I guess
maybe doesn't understand that it's a
draw but now okay now it's starting to
see it yeah okay now it took some time
if you give it to Fritz Fritz won't find
it so I hope you guys can take away some
inspiration and if you guys have any
questions just feel free let me know but
I think we're we're pretty much done so
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]